why ron desantis 2024 stock is rising a
wall street journal story
desantis has burnished his brand with a
covenanting response that has enthused
the voters base of a former president
trump while in florida at least
also impressing the kind of moderate and
suburban voters who turn away from mr
trump in 2020 as the gop
looks to rebuild after losing a
presidential election last year that
formula could give
mr desantis an advantage over rivals who
similarly are trying to forge
their own path in the shadow of trump
over the past year desantis rejected the
advice of most public health experts
and reopened the state's economy early
resisted mass mandates and other
restrictions and made florida one of the
most permissive
settings in the u.s he produced he
received praise from republicans on
scathing criticism
from democrats while sparring regularly
with the media practice that endeared
him
to fans and allies of trump thoughts you
know he's not a lightning rod
like trump is and if you're thinking
about 2024 the republicans have to find
some candidate that they maybe get a
little bit
of momentum behind trump came out the
other day and said i don't even know if
i'm going to run for president again and
if i do i won't
say anything until 2022. so he's really
not really a factor right now
and and desantis is doing well the
state's doing well
um he's likable he's not hated by
everybody on the left
yet so we'll see um i don't know if that
do do you think that's his intentions
maybe to remember
the problem they use with the finger to
show the similarities between him and
trump you know how trump would do the
finger thing well this is the wall
street journal
they're they're they're more sensitive
right i think they're center right i
i trust what the wall street journal has
to say well look
florida for sure was the big winner in
the pandemic okay
texas you know arguably up there as well
uh with
governor abbott um who i guess was
polling around zero
at cpac and ron desantis was pulling
pretty well but florida was the big
winner in the pandemic they did what
they hosted the super bowl they hosted
the nba bubble they've been trying to
get the olympics down here so
credit needs to go to the top he's the
governor he's in charge of florida so
you know he made some magic happen um
but
in 20 in 2024 i don't think he stands a
chance
against the rock so there it is the
santas doesn't stand a chance against
the rock in 2024.
no interesting you think rock's running
in 2024
i i would guess maybe 20 i don't i don't
know how do you run in 2024 against if
you're gonna be a democrat you can't run
he can't run against biden let's not
assume that biden's going to be there
okay you are thinking i have a thousand
dollar bet that he's going to make it
out through this term so this thing's
making you money here with this
i got to tell you you got to have like
i'm not red i'm not blue i'm all about
the green
you know but if you think about it the
state of florida is the capital of the
republican party now that you have the
entire trump family living here
right and you got a strong governor so
watch for him mario hernandez just gave
a hundred bucks and said the fifteen
thousand dollars seems excessive plus
undocumented immigrants do pay
taxes from sales to fed and don't get a
tax refund for
uh or very little well that's true but
they don't pay they don't pay income
taxes that's the difference yeah that's
the difference
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye